and finally new rule the oscars need to
change their name to the debbies
as in debbie downer
because judging by this year's best
picture nominees
you couldn't have a worse time at the
movies if there was an active shooter in
the theater
a new poll found that less than half of
americans now go to church they don't
have to
if they want to feel guilty dirty and
bad they can watch nomad land
that's the one about the woman who winds
up living in her van after her husband
dies of cancer
in judas and the black messiah the fbi
kills the leader of the black panthers
and in the trial of the chicago seven
the fbi kills the leader of the black
panthers again
promising young woman has carrie
mulligan avenging a murderous rapist but
then he kills her too
and she was so close to joining the
black panthers
sound of metal is about a musician going
deaf the father is about an octogenarian
descending into dementia and menari
is the story of dirt poor korean
immigrants in arkansas who put all their
food in a barn
but then grandma has a stroke and burns
it down now enjoy the show
the 2021 oscar is brought to you by
razor blades kleenex and rope
please welcome our host the sad emoji
[Applause]
you know look i don't have to leave the
theater whistling
but would it kill you once in a while to
make a movie that doesn't make me want
to take a bath with the toaster
we
we all had a rough year a little
escapism
would have been appreciated but your
list
but your list of movies it's like the
menu at some stupid trendy restaurant
where all the choices are very
impressive
but there's not one thing i actually
want to eat
where's the comfort food what happened
to
show business did they all decide to
quit cocaine at the same time
did they forget did they forget that
hollywood is still the number one place
to go if you're an egomaniac looking to
fill that hole from your childhood with
applause
at least that's what my therapist says
to me i don't know
they forgot how to help people escape
from their problems and then they wonder
why they're losing their audience in
droves
of course you keep offering up the
immigrant who's [ __ ] in the coffee can
and at some point the crowd is gonna go
oh [ __ ] it just give me the netflix
movie
of motley crew taking drugs and getting
blown
academy nominations used to say look
what great movies we make
now they say look what good people we
are
it's not about entertainment it's about
suffering
specifically yours it's not two hours to
forget your troubles
it's traffic school at the holocaust
museum
in 2021 if you're at the movies and
wondering huh
which one is the bad guy it's you
because you have indoor plumbing and the
nominees don't
this is one reason why godzilla versus
kong
stomped at the box office last weekend
and finally got people back to theaters
because it's godzilla versus kong not
godzilla versus
kong and his crippling battle with
depression
not that i want to see godzilla versus
kong either
jesus is there no hollywood used to know
they used to know how to make a movie
that was about
something
a movie for adults that was also
entertaining
and not just depressing there was
already a category for that
best documentary
you know important filmmaking about the
conflict in syria or the plight of the
hot dog stand owners
you know the part of the oscar show
where you got up and went to the
bathroom
but that's the whole show now they don't
even have a host anymore
the funniest part of the whole night is
the in memoriam segment
[Music]
[Applause]
it's it's such an odd psychological
quirk
i keep asking myself why do so many
liberals have this seeming desire
to want to be sad could it be because
being sad allows you to feel like you're
doing something about a problem without
actually having to do anything
like the poor lady living in her van
there is a solution to homelessness
building affordable housing possibly in
your neighborhood
but
but do people including liberals vote
for that
no they fight it but it does make them
sad
without affecting home values
virtue signaling has already ruined most
of the internet the publishing industry
the new york times and most of the
colleges where football isn't a priority
please at least leave us the movies
because
in all honesty i gotta ask if your movie
is so woke
how come i'm falling asleep
you